les belles la lune elle a inspiré des
écrivains des chanteurs et aussi des
cinéastes les plus récents aussi un et
en plus elle est bien la peur certains
se demandent si elle ne veut pas nous
tomber sur la tête dois-je mettre mon
casque c'est ce qu'on va tirer au clair
dans la nouvelle vidéo
[Musique]
on le sait tous la terre exerce une
force d'attraction sur les obus c'est la
fameuse gravité à huy grave mec oui il
est grave vous connaissez tous
l'histoire d'isaac newton et sa pomme
elle tombe parce qu'elle est attirée par
la terre mais alors pourquoi la lune qui
est attiré par la terre ne nous tombe
pas dessus et bien parce qu'elle fut la
lune se déplace à environ 100 kilomètres
par seconde soit 3600 kilomètres par
heure pour bien comprendre il faut
remonter à ses oreilles il ya 4,5
milliards d'années l'ancêtre de notre
planète qu'on appelle le proto terre est
entré en collision avec une autre
protoplanète que les scientifiques ont
nommé des ja est l'impact entre les deux
oreilles éjecté à grande vitesse des tas
de débris de roches dont certains se
sont ensuite rassemblés pour former la
lune la lune est donc le fruit d'une
collision avec la terre il faut
rassembler les débris ont gardé leur
vitesse initiale acquise au moment de
l'injection et depuis la lumière
pro-serbe jeune fille tu as fumé la
moquette il n'y a rien de fumeux là dans
la lune à conserver sa vitesse initiale
pour une raison simple dans l'espace il
n'y a pas d'air pas d'air pas de
frottement il n'y a donc aucune raison
pour que la lune ralentissent et c'est
parce qu'elles se déplacent à cette
vitesse qu'elle ne tombe
la vitesse et la gravité s'équilibre je
vous montre
d'un côté la lune se déplace à la
vitesse de 3600 kilomètres par heure
mais de l'autre la terre et exerce une
forte attraction et courbes la
trajectoire ce qui l'empêchent de
s'éloigner s'il n'y avait pas la vitesse
elle s'écraserait sur notre planète et
si elle allait plus vite elle serait
plus forte que l'attraction terrestre et
elles s'éloigneront seulement en se
déplaçant à 3600 kilomètres par heure à
la distance à laquelle elle se trouve
vitesse et gravité s'équilibre c'est
comme si elles tombaient en permanence
vers la terre tout en restant toujours
aussi éloigné d'elle au passage c'est le
même principe qui empêche la terre de
s'écraser sur le soleil ouf et c'est
aussi celui qui est utilisé pour
maintenir les satellites artificiels l'
iss par exemple en orbite autour de la
terre alors serait-il possible qu'un
jour cet équilibre seront
et bien non c'est presque impossible un
scientifique américain real un
professeur de physique selanne amusé à
faire des simulations pour savoir quelle
force il faudrait appliquer sur la lune
pendant combien de temps et dans quelles
directions pour lui faire quitter son
orbite il en conclut que même en
poussant pendant une heure avec une
force 50 fois supérieure à la gravité
terrestre la lune ne nous tomberait pas
dessus ouf il faudra en fait une force
encore plus grande où pendant plus
longtemps et ça commence à faire
beaucoup en fait c'est plutôt l'inversé
qui se passe est la lune s'éloigne que
voulez vous monsieur dame
tout fout l'camp enfin bon n'exagérons
rien
tout cela est encore duo force
d'attraction qui créent des marais on
l'a dit la terre attire la lune mais la
lune exerce aussi son attraction sur la
terre cette attraction est responsable
des marées marées océaniques
mais aussi l'arrêt terrestre et j'ai
déjà fait une vidéo à ce sujet je vous
la glisse dans le petit juste là
même sur la terre ferme nous montons et
descendent au sans nous en rendre compte
d'une vingtaine de centimètres deux fois
par jour or ces déformations de notre
planète provoque des frottements de la
chaleur se dissipe bref il y à une perte
d'énergie
conséquence de cette perte d'énergie la
vitesse de rotation de la terre diminue
d'environ 2 1000e de seconde tous les
cent ans ce qui prolonge d'autant la
durée d'un jour terrestre à ce rythme là
les jours seront plus longs d'une minute
dans trois millions d'années mais si la
lune provoque démarré sur terre la terre
en provoque aussi sur la lune qui ont
cette fois une autre conséquence la lune
s'éloigne de nous d'environ 3 8 cm par
an bon c'est vrai sur une distance de
384 400 km en moyenne ça ne se voit pas
beaucoup mais son éloignement aura tout
de même une conséquence observable dans
quelques millions d'années comme la lune
sera plus éloignée de nous elle n'aura
plus la même taille apparente que le
soleil et ne doit donc plus le masquer
totalement et nous offrir le magnifique
spectacle d'une éclipse totale
en revanche cet éloignement ne va pas
freiner les projets de voyage lunaire
les américains vang et envoyer de
nouveaux iman plutôt d'ici 2025 56 ans
après leur première visite une sorte de
seconde lune de miel et ils ne sont pas
les seuls les chinois projette dans
fouler le sol en 2030 et puis
si vous n'êtes pas du voyage rien ne
vous empêche de continuer à être dans la
lune par bref en vain
[Musique]
quant à vous ne soyez pas dans la lune
abonnez vous allez à bientôt les
épicuriens et les épis curieux pourquoi
la faune dufetel défilent et bien j'y
réponds et encore plus de questions dans
ce petit livre réalisé en partenariat
avec nathan vous y retrouverez également
un quiz est un test pour savoir quel
fromage vous êtes personnellement je
suis roquefort
avis aux fondus de lecture le lien est
ici